notre invité philippe léotard connu bien
sûr du grand public pour sa carrière
d'acteur au cinéma participation à près
de 60 films moins connus peut-être pour
la sortie de son nouveau disque
et quand je dis nouveau disque de son
premier disque à l'amour comme à la
guerre
déjà primé par l'académie charles cros
d'où vous est venue cette idée de
chanter maintenant le cinéma de l'idée
l'idéal étant chaîne ben ali déjà c'est
que ce qu'on peut pas le dire nulle part
il faut bien dire en changeant ou sur
scène il faut trouver les endroits comme
les gens qui se sentent en jouant au
football et choses qui n'ont que pour
vous n'est-ce pas dire dans la vie qu'il
faut transposer le haut de forme alors
bon ben je chante depuis toujours et que
j'aime la musique et que j'avais des
amis musiciens et que j'écrivais petit à
petit ça c'est fait et puis maintenant
ce que je disais j'ai eu envie de le
dire une phrase superbe titre verso de
ce disque d'ailleurs il n'ya rien qui
rend la mort heureuse il ya tout qui
rend l'amour amer on l'a vu chez la même
chose en plus la même substance jacques
sylla même instant je crois mais c'est
vrai que c'est insoluble
alors je lui propose sur place le disque
existe vous allez bientôt découvrir la
seine à paris vous allez vous produire à
la cigale les 14 et 15 juin prochain
avant de revenir sur vos appréhensions
peut-être un reportage des lignes thomas
réalisé à lille cette semaine lorsque
vous avez participé à l'inauguration
d'une nouvelle salle l'aéronef et que
vous avez en quelque sorte rodez votre
tour de chant